a slow-motion ballet of shattering
spaceships an army of arachnid Warriors
and the surprising effect that wasn't
CGI at all here's what Starship Troopers
looks like when you strip away the
special effects would you like to know
more
some of the biggest most thrilling
scenes in Starship Troopers saw the
human Heroes taking down the bugs and
one of the biggest is a moment during a
pitched battle between the two forces
that sees the mobile infantry under
attack by a gigantic tanker bug it's a
massive insect the size of an 18-wheeler
and it seems nearly Unstoppable to
finally put it down Johnny Rico jumps
off a ledge and onto its back once there
he blasts a small hole in its armor and
tosses in a grenade that blows it to
Smithereens to film this dramatic
sequence required a mix of VFX both
practical and computer generated as well
as some intense onset stunt work the
latter was achieved by having actor
Casper Van Deen jump from a real rock
face landing on a green foam mat below
later with the use of a CGI stand in and
close-up inserts of Rico the entire
sequence was assembled to make it look
like the gung-ho former High School
sports star was using his fancy football
moves to deadly effect other portions of
the scene require different kinds of
special effects a practical full-scale
version of the tanker bug's back was
created for Johnny to stand on the rig
sat atop a large apparatus capable of
moving the oversized bug prop back and
forth the shell was also recreated
digitally later and the two shots were
seamlessly joined to make it appear as
though Rico was riding atop a giant
tanker bug fighting for his life the
final part of Johnny Rico's takedown of
the tanker bug sees him being thrown
from its back and hiding behind the
corpse of another arachnid when the dust
of the explosion settles he stands up
proudly in a hero moment looking back at
his troops and the audience as the bug
Burns behind him creating just this one
simple shot was nearly as complicated as
the entire sequence first a background
plate was shot of actor Casper Van Deen
standing in front of a practical prop of
a warrior bug carcass complete with
background extras then the burning
tanker bug was created in CGI and
composited behind him many of the big
action set pieces and Starship Troopers
come on the arachnid planet of clindathu
the invasion of the planet winds up
being a botched Mission and a total
disaster for the Terran Federation
filming clindathu meant more than just a
lot of blue screen green screen and CGI
it also required a full-scale set of a
makeshift military Outpost behind the
scenes videos from the making of the
film showed the set while it was still
under construction
interestingly a lot of the seemingly
futuristic elements of the compound were
actually made up of pre-fabricated
buildings from a company called sprung
structures which offers high performance
modular fabric buildings complete with
furnishable Interiors these allow
various Industries to set up working
spaces anywhere in the world quickly and
efficiently and have been used by
companies like Tesla and FedEx as well
as for sound stages for TV shows Big
Love And The Chosen aside from the army
of CGI bugs in fact the entire set is
practical from the buildings to the
desert surroundings a behind the scenes
video from Amalgamated Dynamics also
shows that the carcasses of the bugs and
people Strone about the place were
meticulously sculpted and placed on the
set in in a Sci-Fi movie as ambitious as
Starship Troopers you'd probably assume
that most of the alien Critters would be
computer generated creations and you
wouldn't be wrong a lot of them are vast
armies of CG arachnids were created
digitally to fill the scenes of
attacking bugs but the main Warrior bugs
also had a working motorized full-size
robotic puppet counterpart for certain
scenes including an early sequence that
shows a bug lifting a human soldier with
its massive mandibles the animatronic
was designed and built by VFX icon Phil
Tippett who had previously worked on
Jurassic Park while a company called
Amalgamated Dynamics did the actual
construction and is tippet told cartoon
Brew their usage had a very specific
purpose saying most of that centered
around contact like when you actually
see a real person about to be chopped in
half and the beak of a bug you want to
keep the computer graphics people off
screen as much as possible because they
don't look so good having an actual
moving model certainly adds a to realism
to the warrior bug scenes what you don't
see in the film of course are the
robot's mini operators who control its
movement and action
Casper Van Deen isn't the only actor in
Starship Troopers to get to play with
some big CG bugs his co-star Neil
Patrick Harris who played Military
Intelligence officer and psychic Carl
Jenkins also got in on the fun the mix
of human and CGI happens at the end of
the movie when Jenkins arrives in the
aftermath of a major human victory in a
satirical twist ending Jenkins probes
the mind of the so-called brain bug and
declares that it's afraid while throngs
of soldiers cheer although a life-size
model of the brain bug was used in
earlier scenes this one used the CGI
creation at least for the wide shots
seen in some behind the scenes footage
the bug was portrayed on the set by a
big green stand-in partially covered in
Black fabric this temporary jury-rigged
version would be later removed in
post-production and replaced with the
CGI bug whose head pulsates and whose
body oozes slime as its title implies
Starship Troopers is a about more than
just soldiers it also has a good number
of Starships while there was plenty of
CGI employed to bring some of them to
life many of the outer space sequences
involving ships like Carmen's Cruiser
called the Roger young were filmed using
custom built models one sequence
involving dozens of Starships under
attack used models created by Artisans
at Sony's model shop thunderstick with
George Lucas's industrial Light and
magic and a VFX studio called boss also
lending a hand augmented with the use of
some CG attack ships 13 scale starships
were created for the scene and took a
total of 14 months to assemble from
start to finish the scene which sees
chaos erupt when the fleet meet an
unexpected attack from the bugs required
the VFX team to put together all of
those ships plus background elements the
CGI added later required an advanced
computer software program though even
that could barely handle the task of
compositing so many moving Parts behind
the scenes the large models of the
starships were dangled in front of a
black backdrop to capture just one of
the more than 200 individual elements
the large empty warehouse space stands
in stark contrast to the final scene a
frame buzzing with Starships explosions
and debris during the incredible outer
space action scenes a full-size set was
built of the interior of the Roger
Young's cockpit but for their forward
view into space which showed the
horrific destruction of the Terran Fleet
special digital effects were used rather
than any kind of rear projection or
onset photography instead it was a
standard green screen it wasn't just the
ships out the window that were CGI the
window itself was purely digital as
explained by Sony image Works Scott E
Anderson a flickering light on the
windshield actually put in in digital
that allowed the animators to add in
subtle reflections of the chaos
happening outside the ship just like
you'd see on real glass
for director Paul verhoven getting the
moving lights just right was like an
orchestra in crucial to making the scene
convincing colored lamps were moved
slowly from side to side to cast the
right Lighting on the physical set and
were replaced later by scenes of massive
burning ships and explosive collisions
amid the space Battle Above the bug
Planet it's not just the Roger young
that's taking fire multiple massive
starships are struck splitting open and
jettisoning crew into open space fiery
debris from the entire fleet rains down
as shuttles Escape their motherships and
try to stay alive in the frenzy at least
one of those wrecked vessels was created
with elaborate model work it's just one
of many such ships built for the scene
and it's only when you see the whole
model that you understand just how large
the thing really is ultimately the ship
measured in at a whopping 18 feet and
was built with removable sections to
make the destruction scenes easier to
shoot in stop motion later we also had
two stop-motion animators who literally
frame by frame as the ship pulled apart
bent the metal pieces of the decks it's
mind-boggling how much work went into
each model with astonishing levels of
detail to convince audiences that this
was a massive Starship cut in two by the
enemy the Roger young isn't the only
Starship piloted by Carmen after that
ship is destroyed she also gets behind
the controls of an escape shuttle a
sequence which required a couple
different moments of CGI when Carmen and
Xander reach the shuttle Bay the Pod
they actually get into is real while the
rest of the pods were added in
post-production we only had the first
part of the set and the second of the
part of the set further away in the
background was added later as with the
larger Starship a green screen is also
used to make room for computer generated
images of outer space beyond the windows
of the shuttle footage from filming the
scene shows actress Denise Richards
sitting in the cockpit with her headgear
on and a green screen out the window of
the small vessel as described by Paul
verhoeven the crash and destruction of
the Roger young was crafted in CGI and
placed in the background of this very
shot the foreground was shot on the
gimbals that's where you get all the
trembling and the strains and positions
of this thing these active movements
help give the scene a rocky unsteady
look as Carmen Pilots the shuttle away
from the destruction there are some
tense moments in the finale of Starship
Troopers and one of the most nail-biting
is when Carmen is captured by the bugs
finding herself trapped underground
where she's due to become food for them
she fails to save her new love Xander
who has his head stabbed and empty out
by the brain bug she is however able to
save herself but if you were on the set
of the film The Day That scene was shot
you would have seen something very
different than what ended up on the
screen showing up in more behind the
scenes footage is the moment where
Carmen faces off against one of the bugs
but for the close-up shots of her face
she was actually staring down director
Paul verhoven while he shouted and held
a broom over his head
for shots involving the full bug he'd be
substituted for the full-size Puppet of
the brain book or a CGI model depending
on the shot meanwhile Xander's death was
pretty much filmed As It ultimately
appeared on screen for production built
several models of actor Patrick
Muldoon's head to sub in for
progressively horrifying shots as the
brain bug sucked out his brains all of
this was done in a sprawling indoor set
of subterranean insect caves that was
built for the film
all these practical on-screen elements
just prove how much work went into
bringing Starship Troopers to life and
were part of the reason the film holds
up so well after all these years using
CGI with the light touch to augment the
Practical effects rather than always
replace them outright means that every
piece of the action feels all the more
real to the audience yeah even a giant
oozing brain-shaped bug and strike
oh
foreign
[Music]